Welcome to the Steam Cell!
Yeah!
Hello everyone.
Guys, I just realized this week, I've been fucking up like...
Like on the schedule, I get it right, but then like every time I make my waiting room tweet, I realize I always keep fucking up daylight savings for like JST and GMT.
Because I don't pay attention... the reason why I keep fucking it up is because I'm lazy.
And what I do is that whenever I make a waiting room tweet, I just grab an old tweet.
An old waiting room tweet.
Because I'll be like, alright, I'm streaming at 5pm.
Let me grab a tweet I made for 5pm streams.
And then I just go on Twitter, copy paste as a template.
And then I go, brr, just change the title.
And I go, brr, just change the title.
And the link and then like I don't have to retype the times.
And I was like, wait a minute, why is... this doesn't look...
And then like later I was like, wait a minute, wait.
Daylight savings is a thing.
So I've been like, I realized I've been like fucking up the daylight savings time for my waiting room tweet every time.
For the past week now, I just realized that.
I was like, no, my laziness.
Because why would I retype the time when I already have the time on the waiting room?
I already have like a template for it.
I fucking hate daylight savings time.
It's only invented by like farmers.
Like we don't need daylight savings because we have to revert it anyway.
That's the fucked up part.
Like later on in the year.
We're just reverting our like we're just reverting our change anyway.
So what's the point?
Let's just live a couple of months.
Like let's just live a couple of months.
We're like, you know, the sun shows up later than usual.
Who cares?
Global warming is already doing everything anyway.
If you think about it, we already are getting fucked by global warming.
So it doesn't matter.
What about daylight savings?
Anyway, thank you for the 100 gifted chips.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Also bacon.
Thank you for the 50 gifted chips.
Thank you.
The suns are the weather's already fucked up.
Do we really need daylight savings?
Thank you.
It's true.
You only booed because I'm right.
The weather's already fucked.
We might as well live without daylight savings.
There's like it's so fucked up right now.
In some places.
It's hot when it shouldn't be in other places.
It's snowing when it's fucking spring like what's going on?
But get.
We have to worry about daylight savings.
But yet the farmers are in control of the time.
Sorry.
So I had to get that out of the way.
We have to get out of the way.
Anyway, what's it?
What on?
Thank you.
This is rich.
I think you thank you.
The only mistake farmers make was grow food for other people.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So they give us super chat.
Farmers don't even use daylight savings.
It was invented by a politician who thought kids should get more sunlight.
Oh my God.
That's so outdated.
Like guys, we need to like guys.
I will run for office and get rid of daylight savings time vote for doki bird for president in America.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
As a Canadian, I will run for office in America to get rid of daylight savings.
Oh, wait, I should go for Senator first.
I forgot.
Sorry.
I vote for a doki to be like mayor and then later on vote for me to be Senator and then don't worry.
I will become the house speaker and then like I'll make sure I will abolish daylight savings.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Because that's the only thing that matters.
Clearly, instead of banning TikTok, I will ban daylight savings.
Anyway, JL, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Actually, actually, daylight savings was invented to save fuel for the war effort during World War II.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Okay.
Sorry.
I just need to go through this.
I just need to go through with that because like, oh my God, I hate daylight savings so fucking much.
I really hate it.
Anyway.
So today we are going to be doing Steam Cell.
So how this works knows more politics than the average American.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
I think that's like, I think like people outside of America knows more politics knows more about American politics than the average American.
When you live in America, you make sure you know nothing about American politics because it's it's you just don't want to know.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
But then the rest of the world, we have to know because like everything that happens in America affects the rest of us.
So we're sort of forced to know what the fuck is going on with you guys in America.
Because if something fucked up happens in America, like the rest of us is like we get like partially fucked.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
So that's why everyone outside of America is forced to know what the fuck is going on.
Because we're too reliant on what the fuck you guys do.
Ha ha ha ha.
Except for the states.
You guys have, you guys know all your states.
We don't care.
I barely care about my own provinces.
Do not worry.
I barely, okay maybe that's just a me thing.
I barely care about my own provinces.
I barely care about what like the individual things within the countries.
So like I don't know where, what the fuck my provinces are.
Let alone what 50 states, 50 states.
I almost was like how many states are in America.
Ha ha ha ha.
Do you want like an X amount of states in your country?
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha.
Okay.
I also don't even like.
I don't even know my own nationalities.
I don't even know my own national anthem.
I'll just say.
I know like the partially.
I remember partially of my own national anthem.
And it's like.
Oh Canada.
Our home and native land.
Ba ba da da.
Ba ba ba ba ba ba ba.
Ba da da da da.
Ba da ba.
Ha ha ha.
That's really it.
And then like.
Jazz national anthem.
Chilla.
Ba ba da da.
Ba ba ba ba ba ba.
Because like.
When I used to live in Asia.
Like.
That shit would play almost like every fucking day.
But like.
It's only that part.
Like.
Ha ha ha ha.
It was like.
Ba ba da da ba ba ba ba da da da ba.
I just remember that.
Like.
That's all I can.
That's all I can remember.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
And.
Um.
I don't know.
And then.
Um.
Yeah.
That's the one part I could remember.
And then.
But like.
I know in America.
You guys.
It's like.
What?
You have to do like the pledge of allegiance every day.
And also the national anthem.
Um.
Every day.
Like.
Is that.
Is that true?
I don't know.
I just.
A lot of my knowledge about.
Um.
A lot of my knowledge about like.
Like.
The America.
About America comes from TV.
So.
I don't like to.
Ha ha ha.
I don't remember.
Like.
I just need you guys to know.
A lot of the knowledge I know about what's going on in America.
Is from your TV shows.
So like.
I just know like.
I remember just watching TV.
And they're like.
Time to stand up to do the pledge of allegiance.
And then.
I don't even know.
Like.
I haven't pledged in years.
But yeah.
But that's for school.
That's what I'm saying.
For school.
Oh.
You guys stop now.
The TV lies.
I'm pretty sure like.
A lot of people.
Like.
Outside of America.
Learn about what's going on in America.
Via your TV shows.
Like.
The TV version is better than the actual version.
That's just life in general.
Oh.
Uh.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wow.
Canadian that gets it.
I knew it.
There was a reason I enjoyed your content.
Besides.
All along.
We used to do the pledge in schools.
But they stopped that.
A long time ago.
So.
They gave us the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh.
JL.
Yeah.
We have to do the pledge.
Some schools even enforce it.
And thing.
About under God.
That didn't get added to the 1960s.
They give us the super chat.
Thank you.
That is why you should vote for Doki.
For Senator.
Because I will make sure I will add the ban of daylight savings time.
But don't.
But I.
I just need you guys to know.
By the way.
You guys didn't register this.
This is a joke.
Please don't write my name in any ballots in America.
Please.
I do not want to get into national TV.
For like.
Compromising the vote system in America.
Because you guys have bigger things to worry about.
Okay.
For.
For legal reasons.
Do not write my name in the ballot.
Okay.
Do not.
Please do not write my name.
In any voting.
In any.
In any presidential or senator vote.
In your.
In.
In your city.
I need you guys to know this.
Because.
If you guys don't know.
If a person gets.
You know.
This is going to be a Streisand effect.
Because where I say don't do it.
And then people are like.
You know what.
I'm going to do it anyway.
Because it's going to be funny.
But I'm.
But if you guys didn't.
Me telling you guys this right now.
If you guys didn't know.
If a person has a lot of like.
If a person gets a lot of the written in ballots.
Their name actually gets published.
Out to be like.
A lot of the written in votes.
Were for this person.
So if a lot.
If enough people actually write their name.
On the ballot.
It actually gets published out.
But like.
Please don't do that.
Please don't jeopardize.
Please don't jeopardize a boat in your city.
Josie.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dokey for secretary of defense.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But it would be so funny.
Dokey.
You guys.
Guys.
For all the.
For all.
For all the dragos.
Living in America right now.
You guys have bigger things to worry about right now.
You guys.
I know there's some of you there on the fence.
But I am not the one that's going to be convincing you on which way to vote for.
So don't vote for me.
And you're written in ballot.
Anyway.
Off to like the steam.
The Steam is bringing me sell.
But it's the only way I will pay attention to this.
As a Canadian...
Dragoons.
I do not think that is the right way to go.
Anyway.
Where was I?
But yes, for those who have never done a Steam Spring Cell...
Who has never been to a Steam...
Not just a Spring Cell.
For the Steam Cell streams before.
How this works is that...
Also, if you guys really do want to...
I would be a terrible...
By the way, I'm getting off track.
But I would be a very terrible politician.
Because I would definitely take bribes.
So...
So like...
Like...
If you're lobbying for anything and you have enough money...
I would 100% would take that bribe.
So please.
I would be a terrible politician.
You're like...
But they already do take bribes.
Anyway.
Here up.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
Uh...
Anyway.
As I was saying...
Uh...
For those who have never been to a Steam Spring Cell...
For all of you guys.
And then you guys vote yay or nay when it comes to buying the game.
So you have the power if a dragoon suggests a good game.
But I need to also let you guys know.
Suggest games that you think will interest me.
It might be your favorite fucking game of all time.
But is it a Doki game?
You have to remember.
Is it a Doki game?
Like, I don't know.
It could be the best game.
In your opinion, the best game in the fucking world.
But is it the best game in the fucking world for me?
Like, just remember that.
Um, Louis, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello Doki, struggling game developer here.
Please check out Eden Growl.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, alright.
Maybe I'll do Eden Growl as the...
Okay.
Oh my gosh, I see some fucking curse scratches.
Alright.
Also, the other gamble is...
Okay, so like, now that I'm a streamer, cause in the past, you know, like, I was just like you guys.
The Steam sale would go on, and then all of us would like, pick up games and stuff.
But we would only play like, one to two games of all the games we buy on the Steam sale.
The advantage of being a streamer now is that now...
Um, especially cause it's a single player, I tend to like, stray away from single player games before I became a streamer.
Because, uh, you know, like...
I just played multiplayer all the time.
Uh, cause it's like, you buy like, 200 games, and then you go and play fucking, I don't know, Minecraft or some shit.
That was me.
That was like, before Steam sale was a thing too.
The humble bundles.
I would buy like, so... I would like, subscribe to the humble bundles.
Uh, because I was like, whoa, look at all the fucking bargains from the humble bundle.
And then I would touch like, one of the games from the humble bundle.
Only one of the humble bundle games actually interests me.
And then I just like, that was the only game.
I would have like, 300, like, 100 games from the humble bundles.
And I would only touch like, three of them overall.
But now that I'm a streamer, I can like, share the games with you guys.
But like, as in like, I'll stream for you guys.
Not doing anything illegally.
Not doing any flamboyance.
Just doing everything on my plan here.
I meant, share with you guys.
And you guys live vicariously through me.
By watching me play those games.
So yeah, anyway.
So yeah, that is how it's gonna go.
Let me see what is the first suggestion.
The first...
Oh, I am not playing Kini Topek.
I heard about the Kini Topek does doxxing shit.
And also, I was like...
Gumi played it.
And I was there on her stream.
I was in a voice call with her while she played it on stream.
Oh yeah, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
Her radiance.
Doki, please ban Steam sales.
Thank you for accepting my prize.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh yeah, I'm trying to see which one to go first.
Which one that like...
Um...
Which one I should like, give you guys a vote on first.
There's so many choices to vote on.
The Samurai game.
But that game is so mediocre.
Also, I have three vetoes.
No, no, I have four vetoes.
Just so you guys know.
I have four choice chances to veto a game.
So if you guys suggest a game that I know for sure that I do not wanna play, I will veto it.
But I'll have four.
I can only do it four times.
Alright.
Okay.
Amid evil.
Fast paced.
Nervous.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't think you had proof.
I think you would love it, Doki.
Cheers from a long time fan.
Alright, let's look up amid evil.
Isn't that the scary one?
Wait, I feel like I've seen this before.
Whoa!
Have we watched this before?
Oh, it's like...
It's like retro.
Retro boomer shooter.
It has a volume.
Bum bum bum bum.
Oh my god, you can punch the enemies.
That's not my favorite part because I like to shoot from the...
I realize...
I realize why melee when can shoot.
I can never do...
Oh my god, I recently was playing Returnal recently.
Um...
And like...
Returnal is so fucking frustrating.
It's so frustrating.
Holy shit.
I might play Returnal on stream.
Returnal is basically a rogue-like shooter.
And it's like Touhou rogue-like shooter.
It's so fucking frustrating.
It's so hard.
Amid evil.
The black labyrinth.
Wait, but...
Does he have gun?
Why is it all melee?
Where's his gun?
Amid evil.
Out now.
Alright, it's time.
It's time.
Where's his gun?
Alright, amid evil.
Yay.
Or nay.
It's your choice, guys.
You guys get the vote.
Alright, let's see what...
Oh, it's from the same people as Dusk and Ultra Kill.
I love Ultra Kill.
I don't want...
I'm gonna wait until Ultra Kill is finished finished before...
It's out of like beta before we do like Ultra Kill again.
Alright.
Let's see.
Another low-key game which puts AAA serials and publishers to shame.
Oh, man.
That Battlefront remastered did not...
Do so well, man.
Guys, did you guys see that fucking Battle...
The Battlefront game that was like 75 gigabytes?
That is like...
I think that's like bigger than Dead Space Remaster.
That's actually...
How does that get...
Okay.
So like...
I saw that they were tweeting out early access codes too for this game.
So it's like...
How did no one complain about it during early access?
Like...
How did no...
How did no one complain about being like...
Um...
So I was trying to download this game in early access and it was 75 gigabytes.
Like how did that not...
Like how did that not tell anybody that something was wrong?
Wait, they did?
They did and they still did nothing about it?
I still can't pronounce the devs name.
And I just noticed a medieval pun in the name.
Wait, what?
A medieval?
What's the...
What's the pun?
Okay.
Let's see.
Definitely not a medieval.
Why is this guy complaining?
You know...
I wanna see like...
Okay.
I try very hard to like this game but I just couldn't...
Let's find the one negative comment so I can justify me not buying this game.
You know like those people...
Like when they try to look at reviews and they always find like the one...
The one negative comment and be like...
Look, see?
There's a negative comment.
That means I shouldn't buy it.
And then it's like the one comment...
The one negative comment out of like hundreds of comments.
Like...
There's always one.
See?
The game is not perfect.
Why did you guys suggest this game to me?
Look, see?
If it was perfect, there would be zero comments.
There would be zero negative comments.
I really love this game.
Not recommended.
Alright.
I love retro shooters like Quake and Doom and I thought I could enjoy this one.
However, I found this game very frustrating for a number of reasons.
The level design is very irritating.
Hidden paths and the platform...
This guy...
What?
It just seems like this guy doesn't like retro shooters.
That's basically retro shooters.
Like...
What do you mean?
Hidden paths and the...
Hidden paths?
That's based off of entirely of retro shooters.
And these are like flies.
As long as you stay away from them and use a ranged weapon.
So the game is very easy.
Oh, I like that.
Oh, it's not hard enough.
Okay.
The movement absolutely sucks.
The velocity feels so unreal.
I'd say this game might be worth it to try on sale but I wouldn't pay...
Oh my god!
Lucky for me, it's a Steam sale.
Alright.
It looks like we got a yay on it.
I don't know how much time to give you guys to vote.
I'll just...
You know what?
It's to my discretion.
So sometimes...
Sometimes you guys get a lot of chance to vote.
Sometimes you guys don't.
It's up to my discretion.
Welcome to the Dokiverse.
So, alright.
Yay!
Our first game!
A medieval...
Medieval!
Okay, I just noticed the...
I just noticed a pun.
Okay.
Medieval.
Brutal Legend!
Okay.
That's the...
That's the game with Jack Black, right?
Red Force.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I've bought Brutal Legends for at least six of my friends so far.
Because I love the game so much.
It may interest you.
You might not.
But it's a major cult classic.
Is this the one with Jack Black?
I remember buying Brutal Legends when it first came out on console.
It was like...
Oh my gosh.
I remember buying...
And then...
Did I ever finish?
I don't think I've ever finished it.
But like I played up until like a while.
God, it was so long ago.
This game is so old.
It's 20...
This game was 11 years old.
Jesus.
Oh my God.
You can tell it's old.
I still can't believe it.
I still can't believe Jack Black is gonna be in Minecraft as Steve.
I still can't believe he got casted in Minecraft.
Of all things.
It would be a dream to collab with Jack Black.
What if I like...
Oh my God.
What if...
Okay.
I'm gonna message Mr. Man and ask him if he could pitch to Jack Black.
Jack Black's PR team.
If he ever wants to collab with a Vtuber.
I will pay for his Vtuber model.
DMCA music?
It's alright.
I mean, fucking Freebirds already DMCA'd.
Oh, they're gonna DMCA this stream.
I just realized.
Fuck.
Okay.
Whatever.
I don't need ad revenue on this stream.
It's okay.
I don't...
I don't need ad revenue on this stream, guys.
I don't need it.
By the way, I still haven't been paid.
Okay.
I still haven't been paid by YouTube.
So, like, I technically don't have, like, an income yet.
YouTube side.
Thank God I did have my merch store.
Like, to compensate.
Because I didn't know this.
But, like, when you're starting out a channel, you have to make a ad revenue.
A ad revenue.
Account.
And, like, you need, like, a pin number that they send over via mail.
And, like, so it says in two to three weeks it would arrive.
And so, like, yeah, ad send.
So, for those...
This is, like, a little pro tip for you guys.
Because, like, obviously this isn't, like...
Like, obviously it's not, like, common knowledge.
Because for those who've never been, like, monetized on YouTube before.
So, like, basically what they do is that...
To activate your AdSense account, you need, like, a pin number that they send you.
That's exclusively for you.
But the thing about that is that they send it physically to your house.
Or, like, to wherever you live.
So, like, it says, like, there's no tracking, too.
So, it says, like, it's, like, two to three weeks it's supposed to get there.
And, like, the thing is...
So, I was, like, it's been a month.
And I still haven't received it.
So, I requested another...
I requested them to send it again.
Because I was, like, okay.
It's been a month now.
This is...
Because I asked, like, my friends about it.
And they're, like, yeah, like, yeah, it should take, like...
It took me, like, three weeks to get it.
So, I was, like, okay.
Three weeks is the maximum that I'll wait for it.
But then three weeks passed.
And I was, like, maybe four weeks.
I'll wait four weeks.
Maybe something's going on.
And then four weeks, I was, like, okay.
I should request again.
So, so, like...
So, technically, I haven't received any money yet.
Because, like, they also pay you at the end of the month.
So, like, I was, like, okay.
Maybe by the time I get my pin number...
Um...
I will still get paid for the first month.
But, like...
So, then I was, like, okay.
I'm just gonna request again.
Scott, thank you for the 50 gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah.
So, I'm just, like, waiting again.
I'm gonna wait again to see.
But...
Oh, yeah.
I forgot the vote.
I thought I had the vote on, guys.
Oh, shit.
Did you gift it twice?
I'm sorry if I didn't see.
I thought you give...
Did you give the 100?
Oh, my God!
No, it was once.
Okay.
Oh, my God!
No, it was once.
Sorry.
It just bugged out on chat.
Okay.
Brutal Legends.
It's voting time.
Okay.
Brutal Legends.
Yay or nay?
Yeah.
You guys had, like, so much time to vote for this.
Um...
But, yeah.
It's quite, like...
It's quite unfortunate indeed.
But, like, that means when I do finally have my AdSense account, it would be, like, two months worth of payout.
That's for sure.
Like...
That's a good thing.
I get two months of payout by the time I do get my pin.
But, yeah.
It's a little pro tip.
Like, don't expect yourself to win.
Don't expect yourself to get the...
Get, like, monetized.
Like, get the money right away from YouTube.
Make sure you have a backup plan.
Thank God I have a merch store.
I did not realize, like, how much money you can make off of merch.
It was crazy.
I was like, thank God.
Thank God I opened a merch store alongside of me coming back here because, like, that's practically my income right now.
That's...
Because, like, I do have the money from that.
I don't know.
It's a good thing.
Sgt.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you.
Thank you.
First ever super chat.
Might I suggest and shout it.
Thank you for the super chat, Sgt.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Awesome game.
What an amazing set.
I heard they got a lot of, like, old rock bands for the Brutal Legend.
Rock and metal bands for this.
This is like, oh my gosh, a while back though.
I'm surprised Brutal Legend is still there.
Brutal Legends has not been remastered yet because like, um...
You know, a lot of game companies love to bank off nostalgia factor.
So it's like very surprising to me that they have yet to like remaster Brutal Legends because...
It's DMCA Central.
Yeah, it's DMCA because it was a game made before like people stream and stuff.
But still, I feel like... I guess like getting rights would be really difficult too.
Yeah, I guess I didn't know about music rights.
Usually for games, they only have a license for music stuff for like a specific amount of time.
And then after that when the music license expires, um, they have to like replace the music with something else or they can never re-release it.
So like if Brutal... so like some games and some movies, the reason why they don't get remasters or remixes is because the music license expire and it's so fucking expensive to get the music license that they can't get it.
And then they just say no.
They just say... they're just like, yeah, no, we don't want to deal with that.
It's way too much money.
It's too much money to remaster and give this to you.
Um...
What is this?
I will forever hate this game.
Tried so many times to get it through over the past decade.
Why do you hate this even on easy mode?
I can't get past the ghost rate part.
Halfway through.
There's a reason why no one has ever tried a mashup of these styles in a game like this since it just doesn't.
Bro, why are all these negative comments?
They're just shit at video games.
Like, I think that's literally a skill issue.
I'm sorry, Mickey, for putting you on blast.
But like, what do you mean?
Even on journalist mode, I can't get past the ghost rate part.
Halfway through.
Okay, there it is.
Um...
There it is.
The one negative comment.
Most helpful.
Would have been good if it kept the hack and slash.
But the RTS is awful.
And near the end gets impossible.
Look, there it is.
My token negative comment of the day.
Alright!
Let's see how long you guys vote for.
Alright, yay!
Alright, next.
Brutal Legends.
That is a yay from all of you.
Um...
Alright, next game.
Have you played Alien Isolation?
Yes.
Never again.
Zach, uh, but thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We have part one.
If you look around, you will find the archives.
That's all I can say.
All of my previous stuff I've played.
If you look hard enough, you will find an archive of it.
That's all I can say.
I will not replay it.
I will absolutely not replay it.
Master Chief Collection.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Master Chief Collection is 75% off right now.
Since you said...
Oh my gosh.
Okay, this one, um...
I feel like I don't even need to, like, have you guys vote on it.
We're just gonna watch the trailer.
This doesn't need a...
Sorry, but you're not permitted to view these material at this time.
Why not?
Oh, okay.
Was I just not old enough?
I'm like, what do you mean I'm not permitted?
Okay, we can watch the fucking trailer.
Um, we don't even need to vote.
Because it's obviously gonna be a yay.
I know for sure you guys are just gonna vote yay for this.
But I can play Halo now!
I've never played Halo before.
I've never...
Because I never grew up with Xbox.
So I have no idea what the fuck Halo really is.
I don't know the story of Halo.
The most things I know about Halo is that it's a game.
Halo is red versus blue.
Because of, uh, rest in peace rooster teeth.
I can't believe Ruby graduated.
2024 has been a fucking weird year.
There's so many...
So many, like, old school YouTube people So many, like, old school YouTube people are like, done with YouTube.
It's actually crazy.
Yeah, rest in peace.
And like, Ruby just became like a fucking VTuber too.
They actually became like VTubers.
It's been three months.
I know, it's been three months.
A lot of like, all the old school stuff has been like, super...
They've just like, either retired, quit, or...
or just graduated.
It's actually insane to think about.
Yeah, Ruby was an official VTuber.
It's actually interesting too.
Because like, obviously we're not voting for this because we all know, um, that's obviously a yay.
That's obviously a yay.
Is there a bad Halo game in this collection?
But the reason why I've never played an Xbox...
I've never played Halo before is because Halo was an Xbox exclusive.
And I've never played...
I've never really...
The only Xbox I own was the Xbox 360.
For those who didn't hear this story before, they're all good.
All of them.
Maybe four.
But the more you play the game, the worse it gets.
Because money!
Um, but if you guys didn't know, I never grew up with Xbox.
Because my dad's a gamer.
And he's a Sony fanboy.
Because he loves Playstation.
So...
He's a...
He's a Playstation fanboy.
So like, when growing up, we've only owned Playstations.
I've never like, had a Nintendo console until like the end of the Gamecube life.
And I only was able to get it because it was like for my birthday and I was like begging for a Gamecube because I never owned a Nintendo console because my dad would be like Nintendo's for fucking babies.
I'm like, but I am a baby.
Dad's like, those Nintendo's were for fucking babies.
No Nintendo in this house.
But um, I'm baby.
So I never had a chance.
So the only time I ever got like a Nintendo console was the Gamecube.
The moment it was dead.
Like there was no new games coming out.
So there was a bargain for that console.
And I only had two games on the Gamecube because there were no new games coming out.
And I didn't know what to buy.
And my dad was like, you can pick, usually when you head to like, um, in Canada it would be like EB games.
So my dad would be like, you can only pick one game.
And then obviously I would choose a PlayStation game because a lot of the really good games, the new games, come out on the PlayStation.
So I had to, so I was just like, so I would pick PlayStation games versus old ass Gamecube games.
And the only two games I owned on Gamecube was Animal Crossing.
And um, um, like the Shadow Pokemon games.
I don't remember what they're called.
.
The Shadow Pokemon games.
Those were the only two games I owned on the Gamecube and that was it.
.
Yeah, I call it Xean and Xean.
Sorry, three of them because I bought the sequel too.
I bought the sequel of the Shadow one too.
Um, so those were the old, so yeah, I never grew up with an Xbox.
The only time I was playing the Xbox 360, because my dad like, uh, wanted to play like some Xbox exclusive game on the Xbox 360.
And even then, I didn't even, I didn't play Halo.
I didn't play Halo.
Oh, I think it was Gears of War!
Yes!
The only reason why my dad bought an Xbox 360 was for Gears of War.
.
That was the only time.
That was the only reason why we had it.
.
And then after that, we never bought an Xbox console since.
Anyway, next game.
Sorry, story time.
I'm pretty sure like all the... Halo.
.
Halo.
Good.
.
Halo Reach broke me, but Halo 2.
You know what?
That sounds reasonable.
.
Nice.
Those are good reviews.
.
Nobody will read my review, so I'll just say I'm gay.
Nice.
The chat is going so fast, they'll never know.
They'll never know, guys.
Oh, shit!
Our token negative comment!
.
A wonderful slice of nostalgia ruined by a toxic community.
What?
What does that have to do with Halo?
That just has to do with the fanbase.
Like, the developers can't control what's going on on the fanbase.
Like, that's not their fault.
What do you mean?
Also, like, this guy's a pussy because, like, every multiplayer game has a fucking toxic community.
Like, you can't... like, the first time I ever queued up for Valorant, people were fucking saying gamer words to me.
And I was like, what?
And it was the first...
And it was on Valorant launch.
.
Like...
Like, it was the launch of Valorant.
Like, if a game can't control shit, people are fucking toxic on the launch of a game.
.
It's just always... it's just the multiplayer syndrome.
It's called competitive multiplayer.
.
Alright, let's see.
What else?
What else do we have?
.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It ain't a multiplayer.
People aren't salty.
.
Exactly.
What is self park?
It'll be funny.
.
Please, please, please.
Okay, this one doesn't need to be voted on because I 100% won't play it.
.
Um... the self...
The... what is fract...
.
The fractured butthole?
Yes.
.
Fractured but hole.
Yeah, sorry.
.
I've always wanted to play it out on stream, so don't worry about it.
I'm definitely not gonna play the first one.
I might try to get the Australian version just to, like, not get, like, too .
I don't know if there's, like, super controversial jokes in the sequel to the self park game.
I, like, 100% complete... I never 100% complete games except for the stick of truth.
The stick of truth might be the first game I ever 100% it because I really enjoyed that game.
But, like, I played the original game without the Australian censored version, um, because I mean, it's smart because the original game had a lot of stuff in there that I don't know if I can stream it.
.
So I feel like... I feel like...
I feel like if there's... if it's very similar... if it's very similar in the sequel, I might need the Australian version.
I might need...
.
Just maybe because I don't want to get my channel flagged.
Um...
Let's see.
Uh...
What else?
Let's see.
EDF 4.1 Shadow of New Despair.
Trust.
Liam, thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, what is this?
Earth Defense Force.
The only thing I know about this game is that, um...
it's very popular in speed running communities.
Especially in AGDQDKDF especially in AGDQDKDF DC.
EDF Super Scout News.
We'll fill you in on that and give you the latest information.
EDF.
Oh, the other...
EDF walked so hell divers can run.
Walking Fortress Balaam was deployed to oppose the Erginus.
Giant creatures that appeared from the ocean.
This dependable powerhouse is mankind's mobile stronghold.
And now, equipped with new weapons, it's achieved perfection.
Look at its power.
Strongness.
More than ever before.
Well, I could win without it, yeah.
But it helps for sure.
You sound confident.
I love democracy.
Where's the gameplay?
Oh, there's the gameplay.
I was like, where the fuck is the gameplay?
Wait, how many people can play?
There's so many people.
The environments, the type and number of enemies.
And the locations in which they appear can change drastically.
Oh my god, it's the roguelike.
Because it changes.
There's robots.
I love robots.
... with new weapons, such as the depth crawler.
Oh, four.
Okay.
Bring it on.
It'll keep me from getting bored.
In fact, Officer Honda, wouldn't you say the world looks clearer lately?
Is this like the best EDF?
Because they have so many.
Is this the best one?
It's the jankiest EDF.
Five is the best.
Why did you suggest 4.1?
Alright, if we do yay or nay, we're gonna have you guys vote for which EDF though.
It's quality.
Which makes it the best.
It's the best.
Alright, we're gonna have you guys vote for 4.1 or 5.
Jesus Christ!
This is a 9 minute tre- We're not watching 9 minutes.
Alright, alright.
Clearly this is a yay.
So I'm gonna make another poll.
EDF, which version?
EDF 4.1 5.
Bro, why is this 9 minutes of trailer?
What?
Holy shit.
Oh my god, kinda like Helldivers 2.
If Helldivers 2 Okay, that's good.
That's pretty good, not gonna lie.
Helldivers 2 servers at max capacity.
So I gotta play the next best thing.
Super fun to play Helldivers 2 if it was- Bro, shots fired!
Bro, he put that review at 5.4 hours.
Bro, how do you know?
Jesus, if it was good.
Oh my god.
Bro, that's rough.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
You guys can't watch 9 minutes- Not 9 minutes, but you guys can watch more of this trailer.
I'll be right back.
It's in a lifetime chance.
EDF has four branches.
And your duties will vary depending on which one you join.
But right now, in this specific case, the choice is up to LSTs.
Okay, let's take a closer look.
First, the Rangers.
Thoroughbreds that race across the world.
Just look at that stance.
Not an ounce of fat anywhere.
Look at how fast he stands up.
It's amazing he doesn't get a head rush.
As leaders, they can heal everyone who follows them.
Proving that nice guys don't always finish last.
We'll show you how tough we are.
Next up, Wing Divers.
Angels who dance through the skies.
They're the best.
Their flight suits are highly flexible and maneuverable.
Sexy too.
But more than that, they're stronger now than ever.
Perfect in every way.
Don't worry, we're on the same team.
Let's have fun out there.
Air Raiders dominate with their command of bombardments and airstrikes.
Summon new weapons like Walking Fortress Balamb or Depthcrawler.
Then climb on in.
Your mounted weapons are now equipped with laser sights.
So, even beginners can mow their enemies down.
All units, commence operations.
Give em hell.
Finally, the steel giants we call FENCERS.
Their armor has been reinforced to godly levels and obstacles mean nothing to them.
Their boosters and thrusters can not only increase their speed, but also keep them on balance.
ake.
There is a challenge.
2 2 2 4
4 Always, I'll sell too.
Recount.
Alright, alright, we'll vote for an EDF again.
We're gonna do another vote for EDF again.
At the end of the stream, we'll let you guys vote for like which EDF at the end of the stream, okay guys?
Who said I wasn't just?
I thought 6 was like not out in NA yet.
Okay, I already like EDF 5 more because it's not a 9 minute trailer.
Mom, can we buy EDF?
Can we play EDF?
We have EDF at home.
EDF at home.
Helldivers 2.
Look, it's to the point!
Guys, the trailer's to the point!
It instantly told me everything I needed to know in EDF.
Within a minute instead of 9 minutes.
I killed God and yet ants on the highest difficulty are extremely stressful.
What a magical game.
Fun with friends if you have them.
Oh my god, bro.
Are you...
Oh my god, that's why he has 0.3.
0.3 hours!
Bro!
This poor man!
He only has 0.3 hours on record!
Oh, bro!
Bro!
Okay, it's his old account.
Guys, I don't think we can defend him.
Guys, I know you guys really want to.
But we have to face reality, guys.
Alright, next game suggestion!
Uh, what's this?
One vote for Gurumon.
Sean, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
What the fuck is this?
What is this?
Massive!
Falcon!
What is this?
Oh, yes.
When did this game come out?
Oh!
Is this RPG?
This is an RPG.
What
the fuck is this?
What the fu- Okay, I love the faces of the monsters.
Oh my god!
I love those types of faces.
They're so cute.
Oh my god, monkey!
We need our monkey emote back.
This feels... Oh, this definitely feels like a PSP game.
While watching this.
This definitely...
It definitely feels like a PSP game.
I don't know.
The thing is, it's an RPG game.
That... Okay.
Alright, let's... That's like the biggest part.
I see RPG and I'm like...
Mmm...
I think the last time I've ever played an...
Um...
The last time I've ever actually played an RPG game...
Was... Was it Nioh?
The one... From the creators?
From level 5.
Ah, fuck.
Was that... Was that what it's called?
That was the last RPG game I've ever played.
Uh...
And like...
No, it's not Nioh.
Sorry.
Oh, Noita!
Is it Noita?
Okay.
Is Nino... Yeah, Ninokuni!
Ninokuni!
Yes!
It's about that little boy!
That's all I can remember.
The Ninokuni and like this like pig guy.
That's all... And I only played up to an hour.
And then I gave up.
The only reason why I tried it is because I am a level 5 like fangirl.
And I... I love level 5s like...
Animation style and everything.
And like... Yeah, I only...
That was the last time I've ever played an RPG game.
Because I could only do one hour of that.
Because I was just like... Oh my god.
This is...
I just couldn't... I could not...
I don't... I don't see stick of truth.
Okay, not gonna lie.
I don't see like...
I know like you guys are like...
Yeah, but it's based off of like Dungeons and Dragons.
I don't see stick of truth as an RPG.
It transcends RPG.
Like...
No, no, no, no.
South Park stick of truth is not an RPG.
It is beyond that.
It is a God's gift.
Okay, I shouldn't say that.
That's actually really fucked up that I said it.
If you play stick of truth, that's so...
I'm so sorry.
Let me rephrase it.
The stick of truth is like...
Just...
It is such a good game.
That it has no...
It has no category.
It is...
It is an adventure.
It is like...
An experience.
It has no category underneath it.
So...
So it's not an RPG.
It is an experience.
I refuse to categorize that as an RPG.
Oh wait, I lied.
Baldur's Gate was my last RPG.
I...
I just...
Guys, I couldn't...
I can't...
I played Baldur's Gate for like...
3 to 4 hours.
Like Baldur's Gate 3.
I forgot about Baldur's Gate 3.
Anyway, the last RPG I played was Baldur's Gate 3.
And...
I just wasn't into it.
I'm sorry.
I'll say it.
I just wasn't into it.
I know that RPGs is just something that my FPS brain rotted.
Like...
My FPS rotted brain couldn't like...
Couldn't like commit to.
I know it's a really good game.
I heard it's a really good game.
I tried it.
But my fucking...
My brain has already been like rotted from all the FPS games I played.
That I couldn't sit down for Baldur's Gate 3 long enough.
But I...
But you know what makes me better than some of the other games?
You know the other Baldur's Gate 3 gamers?
I didn't cheese the dice roll.
I fucking committed to it.
No matter what.
I'm already above some people in Baldur's Gate.
Cause I didn't reset when I didn't get my dice roll.
Like some other pussy.
Anyway, that's...
Alright.
Let's see.
Originally a Japanese PC game released in 2004.
Oh my god.
2004.
I thought that was just a stylistic choice.
I mean it makes sense now.
It makes sense.
Gurren walked so Hi-Fi Rush could run.
Oh wait.
Is this like similar to Hi-Fi Rush?
I actually really enjoyed Hi-Fi Rush.
That was a nice game.
I'm glad it won something.
Did somebody else quit right before the final boss?
Because he couldn't figure out what to do?
Hahaha.
Okay.
Um.
As much as I love the old Falcom, this felt rather uninspiring.
Seems closer to Zelda than other series by the same...
Wait.
What other series do they do?
Anyway.
Hi-Fi Rush is not an RPG.
It's like a hack and slash.
It's more like a hack and slash than it is an RPG.
What do they do?
What are games at this point?
What have they done?
I have no idea what any of these games are.
Hahaha.
Haha.
Wait.
Is this even on...
Oh it is.
Four dollars?
Holy shit.
It's only four dollars.
What the fuck?
Alright.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Hahaha.
I don't want to use my veto on this.
I feel like I could use my veto on other things.
I feel like...
I feel like I don't wanna...
I don't want to use my veto on this game.
I don't wanna...
Alright.
Uhh.
You know what game I can't wait to play?
Okay.
Digimon World.
But the good one.
Is this the good one?
Is this the sequel?
Wait.
Is this the good one?
Hasran, Rampart...
No!
This is the...
Wait, no.
Actually, wait.
Which one is the remastered Digimon World?
Is it Digimon Sur...
No.
Which one is the...
Wait!
This is not the remastered, right?
There is no...
Okay.
To be fair.
There was one good Digimon game.
And it was...
Okay.
Like, I said...
I shouldn't say that.
Because, like, Digimon fans...
They are so divided on what is a good Digimon game.
Because in...
In...
In Pokemon.
It's more...
It's easier to tell what's a good Pokemon game.
But, like, in Digimon...
It is...
Digimon fans cannot agree what is a good Digimon game.
Because, like, every Digimon game...
There's something wrong with it.
Every single time.
It is very divided.
So, no one is gonna actually agree what is considered a good Digimon game.
Because everybody don't know what is considered a good Digimon game.
But, personally...
My favorite Digimon game...
Is the original Digimon world.
But that is because of nostalgia factor.
And...
I thought it was on...
I thought the remaster was on Steam.
What happened to it?
Wait.
What happened to the original Digimon?
Wasn't the remaster on...
I thought the remaster...
Or was it on console?
Was it on console?
Or, like...
No, it came out!
I saw it!
I remember it came out!
It's next order?
No way!
It's not next order!
I know for a fact it's not.
It came out on...
On PC.
Because I saw it!
I saw it!
No, I didn't!
They remastered the first Digimon!
Was it called Digimon world?
Okay.
It was like a PlayStation game.
It was a PlayStation 1 game.
And I played it.
And then...
And then they like remastered it.
And then they...
PSP?
They put it on PSP?
I'm so sad.
I thought it was on...
I thought it was on PC.
Who the fuck uses the PSP?
Do people still use the PSP?
I did not realize the PSP is still alive.
I did not realize.
I'm so sad now.
I didn't realize it's still alive.
Who the fuck?
I'm sorry for anyone that still owns a PSP.
But like...
Why?
Why do you go outside and play on PSP?
I can't stand the PSP sliding.
But...
The screen is bigger.
On the PC.
It's bigger.
Me with my PSP.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm sorry.
I'm just sad that it's not released on PC, guys.
Okay.
I'm just...
Look, I'm just salty it's not released on the PC.
Okay, guys.
I'll say it.
I'm sad.
I wish it was on the PC.
Uh...
Kuro, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Highly recommend.
Prey.
It's basically Bioshock in space.
What's this?
Wait, that...
Oh.
Wait, isn't...
Isn't this...
Wait, didn't we have a vote for this before?
I feel like...
I feel like we watched this trailer before.
The world can be spared.
It has to be me.
Isn't that the..
That's Asian guy!
Yeah, I was going to say that.
That's like...
I was going to be like...
Wait, isn't that the Asian guy?
That's like...
Wait, I don't know if I should say that because I was like...
That being my main takeaway from this game from the trailer.
This UK is getting someucha.
I feel like this is definitely... this looks really fun though.
I wonder how long it is.
It looks incredibly long.
2017.
I miss when games took like more than a year to develop.
Those were the good old days.
Now it's all about capitalism and DLCs.
One of my personal favorite games of all time.
Nice!
In a world of malicious sins, Prey is often labeled a masterpiece.
One of the greats.
I wish I could forget the story and play this.
Oh it's like... what is it?
Outer Wilds?
Okay, like I was hanging out with some friends and then like...
I just... I just like... I just like found out about this.
But... but basically Outer Wilds... there's like a server for people who like...
who...
who love Outer Wilds because apparently the story is really good in Outer Wilds that like...
that like people would try to... there's a server dedicated to fighting other streamers who are streaming other...
other wilds so they can live vicariously through that streamer to re-experience other wilds.
And I... I... that blew my mind.
It's like... it's like gotcha viewers.
There's like...
Discord servers for like... like fans of gotcha games where like they would link streamers that are doing gotcha pulls so they can live vicariously through streamers who are doing pulls because they don't want to do the pulls themselves but they want to live vicariously through that streamer.
And that's why whenever like gotcha streamers do pulls their viewers... their viewership like skyrockets really high because they're like... like if their channel gets linked in those servers like it'll be like an ad everyone this streamer is doing a gotcha pull.
Of this game and that's why like their viewership like skyrocketed high for like whenever they do pulls because they want to live vicariously through them but not spend the money.
This is the same with Elder Wilds and I found this out because I have friends trying to convince me to stream elder wilds so they can watch my stream and live through me.
Because they're like... they're like Doki you have to stream Elder Wilds.
I wanna watch you play Outer Wilds!
So like, cuz they're like, if I could, I wish I could wipe my memory of this game so I can re-experience Outer Wilds.
And I'm like, what the fuck?
I was like, what the fuck?
No, I didn't... one of my friends is actually in one of those Outer Wilds discords, where like, whenever someone's streaming Outer Wilds, they would like, watch that streamer.
They don't care who that streamer is.
They just wanna live vicariously through that streamer.
It's actually crazy.
I did not know that.
Like, I didn't realize it had the same commute, like the same like, impact that it does for gacha games.
It's actually crazy.
Oh, there we go!
My one negative point.
My review.
Cannot disable motion flare!
I like how that is the only negative review.
It's the only negative review here.
Wait!
That sucks!
Wait, I can't disable!
You know, bro, that actually...
That sucks though.
I cannot disable motion flare.
Wait, that fucking sucks though.
Wait, that actually...
That actually ruins a lot of games for me, not gonna lie.
Literally unplayable.
Honestly.
It's okay.
We're gonna try.
Pray.
Don't worry.
LordCruises!
Thank you for the superchip...
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
So, the Yakuza fanbase.
Also, I recommend Yakuza, but it's an RPG.
So, I will recommend Devil May Cry 5.
The Devil...
Is that the one with the...
With the emo boy main character?
Oh no, that's not him!
Yeah, I will veto Yakuza because it's like a 100 plus hour game.
I don't know if I can...
I don't know if I can do that.
Oh, good!
It's not with the emo boy, Dante!
I love Devil May Cry.
I...
Like I say, I love Devil May Cry, but I've only played Devil May Cry 1.
It's because I grew up watching my dad play Devil May Cry.
I think I watched him play from 1 to 3.
And I personally played 1 myself on stream.
90% yes!
10% liars!
Who are the 10% that voted no?
Show yourself!
I love the concept.
I love watching my dad play Devil May Cry.
The music is really good though.
I think music like makes or breaks the game.
I would veto Nier.
Because like, Nier is like...
Nier is also like a 100 plus hour game.
It's gonna take me...
It's gonna take me fucking forever to finish it.
Devil...
Okay.
Devil May Cry is so cool.
I wish sex was real.
177 people found this review helpful.
Very powerful.
Wait, why is the chair so powerful?
Only 100?
Well, you better go vote upvote that.
Better upvote that.
What the fuck?
Okay.
5 stars.
Great.
Over the years, I've been stabbed and jabbed by a number of things.
Proceed to stab myself.
Yes.
Oh my god!
This is the first game with 0 negative reviews!
Guys!
It dropped from 90% to 89%?
What the fuck?
Who's the 11% that voted no?
The 11%...
Oh my god!
This is the first game, guys!
The first no negative review game that we found!
Oh yeah!
Thank you for the superchat again for the suggestion!
Okay, here we go.
11% is not motivated.
All right.
And that is it.
Yes.
I don't think we have a no yet.
Uh...
Let's see.
In memory of Akira, I recommend Dragon Ball Z Kakarot.
Oh,
thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Wait, I've only played one Dragon Ball Z...
Okay, it's not on Steam, guys.
Oh, I just spelled it wrong!
Okay.
Okay, wait.
Is it actually not on Steam?
Is it like a Steam exclusive?
Like a region lot?
Wait, is it region lot?
Why is it not...
Do Canadians... Oh, there it is.
What the fuck?
Why did it let me?
Oh, that's so weird!
Is this a fighting game?
The Dragon Ball game fans deserve a little Dragon Ball.
Rest in peace.
I actually... One of my uncles is a big fan of the author.
Um...
Is this... But is this like a fighting game?
Or is this...
It's an ARPG...
Kinda RPG beat-em-up.
Um... And like, not just Dragon Ball, but they basically owned like the whole...
Okay, let me... I'm pretty sure this is gonna be a yay up to 90%.
That makes me...
So happy.
As an Asian that loves sales, that makes me so happy.
But like, basically, I owned... Not owned, sorry, my uncle...
This is the same uncle... You guys don't remember the story.
But this is the same uncle who used to own lots of manga and lots of like Gundam and everything.
And then he got married and the wife told him that he needed to like get rid of half of his collection.
Or like, not half, but majority of his collection.
It was that uncle.
Anyway...
Um... Basically, before he got married...
Before he got married...
Um... I would like...
Uh... Cause like he used to live with his parents.
And then like I would hang out with my grandparents...
At my grandparents' place.
And I would love to like hang out in his room while he's like on his...
Like I would like just relax in his room while he was on his PC doing... I don't know...
Whatever...
Otaku weeb shit he was doing.
And... And I would like...
I would like hang out like...
Like I would just be like on his bed reading his manga collection.
So he had like a huge... Like three bookcases filled with like manga.
And I would like... And it would all be like in Chinese.
So I couldn't really read it.
But I just love looking at the pictures.
And... Um...
He basically had every single...
Uh... Manga that...
Uh... That Kira published.
Every single one of them.
Like the one shots.
Like all his one shots that were put into manga form.
All... Like everything.
Like not just Dragon Ball.
But like...
Uh... Dr. Slump.
And every like obscure...
There was like this one with this vampire boy.
I don't remember the name of on the top of my head.
But there was one with this vampire boy.
And then there was one with this like fox child.
Or whatever.
And...
Like every single one shot he would own.
He was like a super like a Kira fanboy.
And I would like read...
I would just read his manga.
It's not Sand Land.
It was a one shot.
It had like 11 chapters I think.
It's not Sand Land.
It was basically like a...
He had... It was like this ghost fox.
That was... Like it's like this little spirit.
Fox spirit or something.
And it would like...
And then he has to save a hundred people.
Yeah!
He has to save like a hundred people.
To like become a person again.
And for some reason that one shot...
Was like stuck in my mind for the longest time.
And I actually re-read it too.
I like...
Um...
I re-read the manga for that.
Because it was like when I heard about him passing away.
It just unlocked like a core memory of mine.
Of just like hanging out in my uncle's room.
And just reading his manga collection.
I think it was Gogo...
Gogo Ackman.
Yeah, yeah.
Um...
I would have to force her at the speed of light.
If my partner asked me.
He has three kids together.
Guys!
They have three kids together.
Anyway...
Um...
But yeah...
I would...
I just remember like just...
Um...
But yeah...
He was like a huge...
Like he had every co...
Every...
Just everything.
I just remember he had the full collection of Dragon Ball.
The full collection of Dr. Slump.
Every single manga that he has published.
He owns it.
And he was a like super Gundam builder.
Um...
I will not be seeing the ones who like Gundam.
I guess.
Um...
Let's see.
Rest in peace.
Oh...
Are you crying, son?
No!
Oh my god.
Who the fuck said...
Who...
Oh, this was like before.
Okay.
Um...
Oh, it's just DLC.
Everybody hates DLC.
If it's super overpriced.
No!
Alright.
That's a yay.
I don't think we have a...
Yeah, we don't have a single name yet.
Um...
Alright.
What's this?
Duck of Life!
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright.
What's this?
You know what I can't wait to play?
I need to get like people though.
I need to like recruit people.
Like...
It's so hard finding like people to play collabs.
Like reaching out.
Because I can't add everyone anymore.
I can't...
I can't add everyone.
I have to actually...
So sure reach out to people.
There's one game I really want to play.
And it's Duck Game.
Because it's such a fun game with friends.
I have to DM people.
Nah!
Socializing.
I love Duck Game.
Oh, I already voted for this!
This was a yay!
Well, this was a yay.
We don't need to...
We don't need to look back.
I will give you guys previous yays.
Okay?
We don't have to...
We don't have to like vote again for old yays.
I remember we yayed this.
We yayed this before.
Ummm...
I'm suggesting a hat in time.
Because it has a 50 player co-op.
If you...
What?
Like...
Modded or actual?
What do you do with 50 players and hat in time?
Isn't this a platformer game?
Isn't this...
How is this a 50 player game?
How?
Where do the hat of 50 players do?
I remember when this game was a Kickstarter game.
The rare moment when Kickstarter games turned out okay.
By the way, I kickstarted that...
What was it?
That rhythm game?
With like the boyfriend girlfriend shit?
Fuck.
What was...
Friday Night Funkin'?
Bro, what the fuck is going on with that Kickstarter?
I think...
Did the devs run away with our money?
There hasn't been an update to it in like...
Fuck a year plus I feel like.
Bro, did you hear the...
Did you hear the rumors?
Did you guys hear the rumors?
That the dev is out there fucking...
Sipping Coca-Cola?
Read between the lines.
What?
I saw the fucking rumors and I was like, what?
I don't know if it's true or not.
I don't know.
I just heard the rumors and I was like...
And I looked at the...
I looked at the Kickstarter and I was like...
There has not been an update in a long time.
And I was like...
What's going on?
What's...
It's not...
It's not true.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
Because like...
The thing is...
There was plausible like...
There could be plausible truth in it.
Because like...
Ever since...
A lot of...
Friday Night Funkin came from Newgrounds.
Yeah?
But the thing is...
Like...
There has been like...
Artists and like voice actors that came from Newgrounds that spiraled hard.
So I was like...
I was like...
Okay.
There could be like plausible truth because of the...
Because...
Due to...
Due to like past experiences with other creators on Newgrounds.
So I couldn't...
I was...
Okay.
I have a lot of my humor and a lot...
Like you can tell that I was a Newgrounds kid due to my humor.
Because I grew up on Newgrounds.
Like...
You can...
It's super fucking wild.
But like I didn't grow up on that side of Newgrounds.
The...
There's like two sides of Newgrounds.
The one that's there for obvious like R18 shit.
And the other side that really enjoyed the games and animations that were not those.
So...
I don't know.
Is that Egoraptor?
First time reviewing a game.
Got a cat here.
Friends passing by.
You can touch him and click like to pet him once.
This game is good.
Play it now.
The best 3D platform I played in a long time.
The thing is there hasn't been like a lot of...
Like 3D platformers are not the meta.
So there haven't been the...
Like good platformers in general.
Um...
You were a Henry St- No, I was like more of the edgy ones.
Like, I liked the, you know, like the tank men shit and um...
Back when Egoraptor actually animated stuff.
I was like so hyped for any like Egoraptor animations that would come out.
And also like, obviously I shouldn't be watching those things back then.
And uh...
And then also like, what was it?
The Alice Returns.
The Alice games I remember very fondly of.
I don't remember what the game was called.
The Alice games.
And uh...
And then obviously like Alien Homin- like Castle Crashers when it was a Newgrounds game.
And...
There's a lot of- I just remember like snippets of stuff.
And then all the animation.
Oh, Ed's World too.
That was on Newgrounds.
Rest in peace!
I remember when I saw a YouTube channel when he was like talking about like his hospitalization and stuff.
And I was like, oh my god.
I was like- like as a fucking- that would- gave me like trauma.
Cause I was a kid.
I like seeing that on YouTube.
Like I was like, holy shit.
Like as a kid seeing that.
Um...
No, no.
It's like a Newgrounds game.
It's not American McGee's Alice.
Great game too.
I wish there was a sequel- like I wish they made more.
Cause I really enjoyed the lore and the art direction of Alice.
Um...
But like...
Honestly, I heard like American McGee is very- as a developer...
Um...
I'm trying to put this nicely.
Like...
I'm trying to figure out a way to put this nicely.
Oh yeah, Alice is dead!
Alice is dead.
That's a good game.
Like that's on Newgrounds.
Like that's a good game.
But he...
A bit of a diva, I would say.
A bit of a diva.
Um...
Let's see.
Uh...
Yes!
Okay, Haddon Tom.
That passes.
Uh...
Let's see.
What else?
What else do we have?
What about Space Marine?
Uh, Imagina!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Be a big ass armor guy crushing Xenos!
Also, you should check Boltgun again to finish the job!
Okay, Space Marine.
Space Marine!
Ghost Trick, I wouldn't vote for it because honestly...
Uh, Ghost Trick, I really want to play it in the future.
So we don't need to vote for that.
Is this the... retro?
2011.
I wish Gears of War was an Xbox exclusive.
Or Microsoft exclusive.
Oh, gee.
I can't wait for the sequel.
The sequel looks really fun.
For the Emperor!
Brothers!
I have known nothing about Warhammer except for the Space Marines.
I feel like every...
Like all the normies outside of the Space...
Like the Warhammer...
The Warhammer fandom only knows about the fucking Space Marines.
I don't know anything else about this game.
About the lore.
We are Space Marines.
Brothers!
I am war!
I can play this now!
Brothers!
Wait, what?
This game is just like...
I scroll down.
The first...
The first review.
This game is great.
But what the fuck is this shit?
$60 for a decade plus old game?
That's simply bundled together with DLC?
There's nothing new in this anniversary edition.
Raised up price like a million dollars.
A greedy mega corp just before the release of Space Marines 2.
Pathetic.
Bro, look at him.
Didn't wait for the...
What the fuck...
80% off!
Look at this guy.
Didn't wait for the steam sale.
Bro literally could have waited a month later.
He's not a brother.
Look at this brother!
The fool!
Look at him!
Also I was gonna say, like, that's just the Nintendo way.
But when Nintendo does it, no one gives a fuck about it.
Or they just too scared to complain.
I'm too scared.
I'm honestly too scared to play Nintendo games on YouTube.
I might need to ask my manager how to avoid angering Nintendo.
Like, on Twitch?
On Twitch it's easier.
Because, like, the reason why people can stream Nintendo games very easily on Twitch is because the streaming policies on Twitch is a lot like...
Like, you can't really, like, copyright strike people on Twitch regarding... other than music.
For game-wise, it's, like, almost impossible to do on Twitch.
But, like, on YouTube, it's obviously... a lot of people like to abuse that system.
Unless... yeah.
Unless, like, you have, like, you have to sign up to something.
Because I remember, like...
A long time ago, I remember reading about this.
That, like, you can, like, sign up to be, like, a official Nintendo content creator or something on YouTube.
But you need to, like, apply for it or something like that.
So they won't, like, automatically, like, strike your videos when you're playing Nintendo games.
And that's for, like, outside of... like, outside of Japan.
So, like, I don't know if that's still a thing.
I just need to ask Mr. Man about it.
So I don't know if the Partners Program is still a thing.
For people in... people in NA.
So I don't know.
It's not?
So, like, I don't know.
Like, the thing is...
I don't want to piss off Nintendo.
It's not... I don't know.
I'm not updated in, like, the new shit of what Nintendo wants now.
So, like, I need to see.
It's no longer a thing?
Okay.
Alright.
But even then, I need to make sure that everything is okay.
When it comes to me streaming Nintendo games on YouTube.
Because, like, I don't want it.
I'm...
Nintendo is, like, one of the...
I don't...
Nintendo is, like, one of the only companies that I'm scared of when it comes to, like, game permissions.
Every other...
Like, because, like, every other time...
Through, like, history...
Whenever, like, any other company but Nintendo, like, try to strike somebody on YouTube...
It turns into huge news and stuff.
Because people will be like, Whoa.
That's a little extreme.
So, no companies want to risk that and stuff.
Because, like, it just gives negative publicity.
But, like, Nintendo-wise is the only company I'm scared of when it comes to game permissions and things like that.
Like...
So, that's why I'm not risking it.
Like, I need to make sure I am safe when it comes to Nintendo games.
But also, I'm not...
Also, like, IMO...
There's, like, not really a lot of Nintendo games I would want to, like, actually stream.
Because, like...
I'm not, like...
I don't know.
There's, like...
I'm not, like...
I didn't grow up with Nintendo.
So, I don't have the huge nostalgia factor playing in on anything.
And the only thing I like about Pokemon is, like, the OG...
Like, I'm not a fan of the new Pokemon series other than the Legends stuff they've done.
But, like...
Because Legends was, like, new.
It was, like, a new way of doing Pokemon.
But other than that, I didn't grow up with nostalgia for Nintendo games.
Because I didn't grow up...
Like, my dad didn't let me play Nintendo games because I didn't have consoles for it.
So, I literally have zero nostalgia for Nintendo.
So, like...
Whenever, like, a new Nintendo game...
Comes out, I'm not, like...
Like, it doesn't really affect me too much type deal.
I prefer Crash Bandicoot racing game versus the Mario Kart.
I honestly think the Crash Bandicoot racing game is better than Mario Kart for me.
Like, after playing both of them, I like the Crash Bandicoot one more.
Yeah.
The dad moves too slow.
Strong.
Let's see.
Alright.
Space Marine.
That is a yay.
I feel bad for the first person who gets the name.
I'm so sorry if you were in the first one.
Let's see.
Great.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I heard somebody say Project Nexus.
I concur 100%.
That is a great game.
Project Nexus.
What is that?
Let's see.
Wait.
I know this game.
Wasn't this a Newgrounds game?
Or was this from a Newgrounds creator?
I've seen their animation.
Yeah.
I told you I'm a Newgrounds.
I grew up on Newgrounds.
Like, I recognize the game.
I recognize this.
Yeah.
This room looks...
This reminds me of...
Fuck.
What was that?
Hotline Miami?
It's like feels...
The gameplay seems very similar to Hotline Miami.
It's a third person...
Run and gun beat-up.
Filled with arcade style action.
20...
2021.
Oh, this is recent.
Let's see.
I don't know if it's good or not.
I think I need to play...
What?
Holy fuck!
I was like, wait.
What do you mean?
Bro, this man has 857.7 hours.
Bro!
What?
Okay.
I need to see if his account is public.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Guys, I think he really likes...
I think he really likes this game, guys.
I love Madness Combat.
She yanked all my...
What?
Oh, she ha...
That doesn't make more sense to me.
I regret refunding this game.
Okay.
Peak gaming right here.
You can grab a fire extinguisher and beat people.
A little bit.
10 out of 10.
All right.
I need to check this guy's profile.
Guys, I think he really likes Project Nexus.
Bro.
Bro, he got everything.
Holy shit.
Sorry for doxing you, bro.
But bro, he has all the achievements.
Holy shit.
Bro, maybe...
Maybe he really likes this game.
He likes Project Nexus, guys.
I think he really likes this game, guys.
Holy fuck.
Bro, his review is...
I got to play more.
His review was like, I got to play more to make me sure.
Oh my...
He knows...
He knows what's up.
He really, really, really likes it.
Liam.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Rain World is a 2D survival platformer where you are the prey animal in a simulated ecosystem.
The other wilds is a 3D...
Okay.
Other wilds, I'm definitely going to do it in the future due to peer pressure.
Due to peer pressure from my friends.
So, like, don't worry about that.
That, you don't need to vote.
Okay.
Rain World.
Let's see.
Okay.
What is this?
You're a nomadic slug cat, both predator and prey in a broken ecosystem.
Grab your spear and brave the industrial waste, hunting each food to survive.
But be wary, other bigger creatures have the same plan.
And slug cats look delicious.
It's like jelly.
You will suffer in this platformer.
That's the trailer?
Does it just end like that?
Oh, I guess it's like gameplay trailer.
I don't know.
I was going to be like, wait, what the...
It just ends.
Where's predator?
The old world died.
A new ecosystem evolves.
Kill.
I'm mad that Mark...
Okay.
How long is this game though?
There might be a reason why you didn't finish it.
Because, like, for...
Okay.
Variety streamers...
Here's like a little streamer tip for you guys.
The thing about variety streaming is that, um, unless you're like, you're like a certain focused gaming stream, like in terms of like your focus on like a certain genre.
For variety streamers, there is a limit on like how they think is like viewer retention.
And I point because in the past, let's plays were very common.
It's very common to do let's plays.
But streamer meta has evolved to the extent.
Where like if you're a variety streamer, um, you can't, you can't do long let's plays anymore.
Or you have to do edited content.
Uh, because like, so unless you're like a heavy focused genre for a specific genre, you can get away with that.
But you're in variety streaming.
Longer gameplay playthroughs are now not meta anymore.
So, so it's like, obviously the more you play the same game, uh, the more you play the same game, the less viewers you're going to have.
Um, this doesn't apply to multiplayer.
Multiplayer obviously.
Uh, multiplayer games, it's like competitive and stuff.
But you're playing, if you're a variety streamer, uh, it's harder to keep up.
So like for me, my, I've learned that my hard limit for like, for like, uh, long playthroughs is 3 to 4.
3 to 4 streams usually.
That's the average.
So like, my goal is to always complete a game within 3 to 4 streams.
Because that is like, the limit.
That's like the viewer retention and everything.
So it's like, you gotta figure out like, what is your like, hard limit when it comes to like, longer playthroughs of streams.
Because, um, when you play the same game for a very long time, people will like, eventually get super bored of it.
And that's like, the biggest issue of being a variety streamer.
Uh...
Let's see.
I wish somebody would make a world re-
Um...
It's cause, it's cause short form content ruined us.
Like, TikTok and YouTube, like, like TikTok and YouTube, what the f- It's fun to die over and over and over and over and...
What the f- But yeah.
The TikTok and YouTube shorts basically brain rotted a lot of people.
Um...
There is no other game to my knowledge that does what RainWorld does.
There is no other game that can create an environment this alien alive.
And what the f- Is it playing the same thing again?
Oh I didn't pause it.
I was like, what the f- am I even listening?
Oh yeah.
You're more of a casual gamer.
Do not recommend it.
Grew up- gave up after barely getting a third of the story.
All right.
Easy man!
What?
Bro!
Wait, no he didn't.
He kept playing.
So... This liar!
Oh.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
The above paragraph was what?
It was 8 hours.
Now after 40 hours, I beat the game in easy mode.
But cheating sometimes by using the warp mod because the game...
God, my nerves!
Bro, this man modded his game!
So he can finish it faster on easy!
That's not a casual gamer!
That's journalism mode!
I'm so sorry if you're watching this stream.
But like, you gotta accept that.
Like, that's not being...
At that point, like you're not a casual gamer at that point.
That's like actually like... Like you're below casual gamer.
The fun I had playing it in some parts was...
Offset by frustrations that adds nothing to the game in my opinion.
I would have loved the game if it was like Katana Zero...
Where the checkpoint is at every screen or something of the sort.
The problem is not having to deal with a challenging situation.
The problem is having to pass all through the easy part you already passed...
So that you face the challenge again.
Bro, this guy should never play a Souls game.
Like...
Okay.
Let's see...
I played Call of Horrors before.
It said, thank you for the magenta soupa.
Thank you, thank you.
We played it before.
Like I said before...
If you guys didn't know I played these games before...
You can...
If you look hard enough, you'll find an archive.
If you look hard enough, you'll find an archive of it.
Let's see...
Shark, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Bomb rush cyber fight.
Really fun gameplay and amazing aesthetic.
Alright, here we go.
Let's see...
What is this?
Woah!
Woah, this music.
Wait, is this a spiritual successor of...
Um...
Fuck, what was it?
This is a spiritual successor.
Oh, Just Set Radio!
Yes!
Just Set Radio!
This is basically like Just Set Radio.
I've always wanted to play Just Set Radio.
So I've always wanted to play Just Set Radio.
But you made it
up, come on!
Missing With Life.
I wish there was a remaster of The Rapping Game.
What was it?
Paparappa?
I forgot his name.
I didn't grow up with that game.
But I've always wanted to play it.
Loud.
Okay.
I wish they did a remaster of that.
That's a good one.
I've never played it.
I've always seen memes about it.
And by that I meant...
The one that I remember is the one with Batman.
This is where my parents died.
Alright, let's see.
What are the reviews?
Exploring Five...
So they say to hit the graffiti spots and get the rep.
You'll need to challenge the rival crew.
Is this skateboarding?
Oh yeah, it is.
Skateboarding.
This is just Radio 3?
Wait, why?
Why do we need to play this game with...
Bro, what the fuck?
What is he... Why?
Please play this game with mods.
I know people judge me for this.
But I only ever bought this game because I saw someone playing as Sonic.
I thought that was incredible.
Jet Set Sonic being a real thing made me happy.
And the fact that I can add my...
Okay, there's even multiplayer mode.
But like, why does he have so many mods?
What are all these mods?
Disable annoying cutscenes.
Final score that gives me my boost rebound.
Custom group just sit down.
Photo storage...
Bro, that is so many mods.
That's not just Sonic.
To get you started.
Like better...
What the fuck does better...
What the fuck does BRC toilet mean?
Like...
Bro...
Better toilet?
Why is there a toilet function?
My favorite Sonic model is the 06 model pack.
Has a tendency to crash games.
I don't think it's this mod that has a tendency to crash games.
I think it's all of this.
I like how he's like...
Yeah, by the way, this mod tends to crash games.
I'm like, no!
Look at all these mods you have!
Bro...
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Okay.
And you should be good.
Holy fuck.
Like, yeah!
Modding's great and all.
But this is way too many!
For like...
This is not Skyrim!
This is fucking...
Bomb Rush Cyberpunk!
Like...
Better toilet is crucial.
You seriously?
Yeah, I was gonna say this looks like a fucking Skyrim mod.
Um...
This game will get you laid.
Nice.
Alright.
Hey, don't kink shame.
You should see my Arma 3 mod list.
Uh...
Let's see.
Come on!
Thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you, thank you!
Okay, I've always wanted to play Hollow Knight.
But I heard it's like...
It's like such a long-term commitment.
I feel like I rather...
I'm gonna...
The reason why I haven't played Hollow Knight yet...
Is that I'm low-key waiting for...
Uh...
I'm waiting for like the sequel of Hollow Knight.
Um...
Cause like...
That's the one I'm waiting for.
I don't think I need to do a yay or nay for this.
But like...
I've always wanted to play it.
Hollow Knight is like one of those games that...
Even though I know it's like a super long game...
I was like...
I'm honestly like super curious.
But I honestly sort of want to wait for...
Silksong.
Wait.
What do you mean it's not...
Wait, what?
What do you mean?
What do you mean it's not coming out?
There are so many trailers!
What do you mean?
Don't say that!
There are so many trailers!
Every...
Don't come out!
No!
Yes!
But that's when you know it's a good game!
That's when you know, guys!
You just gotta believe!
Guys...
Guys, we don't want it to be like all the other fast track games.
Don't worry.
I will wait a hundred years for the sequel.
For a game I've never played before.
For the sequel of a game.
I'll never play.
300k reviews.
That's actually...
Honestly, I'm curious.
I'm curious.
Who fucking gave a negative review?
Like, it's...
Oh, wait.
There's a guy right now.
Obviously, I'm not far enough in the game.
Though I absolutely love the art style.
I find the game far too...
Okay, is it all the negative reviews just skill issue?
You are but...
Grim is hot.
Silksong.
Okay.
So, Sucks is a lie.
I don't know what the negative reviews are...
For this.
Okay.
Negative.
That's like 9,000.
Artificial...
All of this are like...
Game is full of bugs.
What even affected my dreams?
Don't buy it if you don't buy it.
What the f- Cat sex the hornet!
Stop looking at negative reviews and buy this game!
I love how like...
Good game might just have skill issues!
All the negative reviews are just like...
Skill issue, I'm not good enough for this game.
He knows!
Um...
Uh, garlics, thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you, thank you!
Don't wait for Silksong.
Hollow Knight is one of the best Metroidvania games ever made!
If not the best!
Nobody who enjoys Metroidvania style games should go without playing it.
Bro, this guy, I bet you, this guy...
This guy was the one that wrote this review.
Silksong is the one!
It's him!
True!
Alright.
Alright, we're gonna look at... We're gonna look at, uh...
I'll give you guys 3 more games, guys...
We're gonna look at 3 more games and then we're gonna call it here, we're gonna call it here.
Adon!
Thank you for this super chat!
Thank you!
A second inscription...
It's one of my favorite games and it's won Game of the Year when it came out.
It's a roguelike deck builder.
Is that like... wasn't there like a new roguelike card game that came out as well?
I don't remember what it's called.
It is...
What was that game called?
The newest one?
I almost said Boruto.
I was like, wait, no, that's the sequel of Naruto.
It was so similar!
Who the fuck is this guy that's streaming it?
And it's not me!
Alright.
Let's see.
What was it?
Baloutro?
I've heard about this game.
This game was like a streaming meta game.
When it came out.
Inscription.
Yes or no.
What the fuck?
Yeah, I heard like the...
Baloutro seems to be like a really fun game.
I've seen a lot of people playing it when it came out.
I don't know what it really is though.
I've never really been like a card game player.
I have no idea what to do.
Because it requires a lot of reading.
And a lot of like using your brain.
Which is honestly like one of my negative traits.
Not the reading part.
I can read.
But...
Just...
I can read by the way.
It's more so of...
Of the...
It's more so of the thinking part.
Let's see.
I actually don't know how to play poker.
I watched my dad play poker.
My dad would play like this...
After...
He would play those like...
Oh my gosh.
If you lived in Asia, you would know those card games.
Like the one with the...
Like the online...
It's not like...
It's like...
Chinese online poker.
Where like there was like avatars and stuff.
And you can like dress up your little avatar.
It was like a blue background.
And then you can like dress up your avatars and stuff.
Like it was like Gaia Online.
And...
I would just watch him play that game.
And then like...
The more money you win, the more you can decorate your avatar.
And it was so...
Cause like...
It's like a point...
Like you don't win real money.
But it was like point system and stuff.
No, it was poker.
It was like...
It was so funny.
So like...
You can tell like who doesn't have money cause they're naked.
They will be on their underwear.
And then...
And then like my dad was like super decked out.
He was like super decked out.
With like costumes and everything.
And there's like cutscenes.
There's like animations if you win the game.
That's so dumb.
Let's see.
Why are you reading this?
Just play it and play along.
He turned the computer into a funniest shit I've ever seen.
Surpassed all my expectations.
Go in blind.
Don't look anything up.
One of the games I played.
So much effort.
Sweet.
Thank you for the 20.
Get the chips.
Thank you.
Uh...
Oh, okay.
It seems like you have to go in blind.
For this.
It seems like a cool game.
But just me learning the basics makes my head hurt.
Head hurt.
Tell me hurt.
Don't worry bro.
That's gonna be me.
0.3 hours.
Refunded.
That's gonna be me guys.
That's gonna be me.
Head hurt.
Brain hurt.
Um...
Let's see.
Sleeping dogs.
Hey boy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We're not gonna do yay or nay sleeping dogs.
Because that's one of the games that I wanna play in the future.
This is one of the games I wanna play in the future.
So we're not...
We don't have to vote for sleeping dogs.
Let's see.
What else?
I'm looking at like...
Indie game suggestions!
Gee, thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you, thank you!
King of the castle!
It has Twitch integration so you can play against all the dragoons in the chat.
You play as the queen while all of your chat are backstabbing nobles trying to dethrone you.
It's only like 7 bucks.
Okay.
What is this?
What the fuck is this?
It's not fair!
You're all just gonna fucking dethrone me!
How is this fair?
Like, why would I play this with you guys?
You're all just gonna try and like sabotage me!
It's not even gonna be a question!
That's the idea!
God, that's a lot of politics.
We would never...
How could you say that about us?
Is that it?
I don't know what's going on.
I don't know what's going on in this game!
In king of the castle you wear the crown.
Make difficult choices that will bring your kingdom into prosperity.
For chaos.
Wait, only three people?
I thought it was like...
Oh, unless like...
The Twitch integration can be like one person.
I'm too dumb for this.
Don't worry, Doki.
Thank you, the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Oh, you can do teams!
Alright, what are the comments?
Your majesty, there's no such thing as absolute powers.
What's the point?
What's the...
What's...
What's the point?
Wait, it really depends who you're playing with.
The nobles have to be really into the screen and commit it.
I think nobles need a little more to do.
More magic, more intrigue.
It's a nice party game, but stay away if you have a wide screen or ultra wide screen.
Okay.
I got murdered three times by my friends repeatedly, but I kept coming...
Guys, this is gonna be me!
Guys, this is...
I'm redoing this.
Wait, what?
My friend got killed by G-Dragon?
Oh, Jesus.
10 out of 10 game?
Guys, I'm redoing this.
You guys are just gonna keep killing me!
How am I supposed to enjoy it?
I'm vetoing...
This is my only video.
I'm vetoing this.
I'm gonna veto this.
No, I had...
That's one...
I'm only vetoed once and this was the only video.
This is literally the only video that I've had.
I'm not gonna let you guys kill me non-stop.
Alright.
Last game suggestion.
This is gonna be the last game suggestion, guys.
Last one.
Okay, let's see.
Which one should I... Oh, this is gonna be...
This is gonna be scary.
Which last game are we gonna play?
Let's see.
Uh...
What is this?
Peaks of Yore?
You know what, Lance?
Good job for you.
Because this is a game I've never heard before.
Peaks of Yore.
What is this?
Okay, no.
This is my second veto.
We got another suggestion.
We can look...
Guys, I'm gonna look for one more suggestion.
We're not doing Peaks of Yore.
This is veto number two.
Okay.
Okay, we're good.
Alright.
Who wants to give me their last game suggestions?
Alright, here we go.
I don't need a try!
It's a climbing game!
I don't need a... Look!
It's literally a climbing game!
What do you mean I didn't give it a try?
We already have a climbing game.
We don't need another climbing game, guys.
We don't need another one.
What the fuck?
Garfield lasagna party?
Okay, this is... Okay, this... I just need...
Oh, I like how it says Soul Slayer.
This is not multiplayer.
This is local player.
It's not a veto.
It's more like... It's impossible to play with anybody.
Because it's a local... It's not online multiplayer.
It's local player.
I know because I actually looked it up.
And the reviews were like, oh, you can't fucking play with people online.
Alright, this would be the last game suggestions from Deadpool.
Last suggestion of the day.
Off-climb game.
Thank you for the super chat, guys.
Thank you, thank you.
What is this?
Is this just an animated trailer?
It's a reverse horror game in which you... Oh!
What the fuck?
Wait, I think I've seen this game before.
I think I know what this game... Oh my god.
You are the spooky monster?
So what's the difference?
Nice.
I consume all.
What?
Oh, he got hit.
Oh!
Oh god!
Oh god, where's the gameplay?
Oh, there it is.
Can you die?
Wait, they can't shoot.
How do you shoot a blob of mass?
There's no head at that point.
Yeah, it's like the thing.
Oh god.
It's like... This is like rated... Rated... It's like R18 Super Meat Boy.
Wait, this is!
This is like if Super Meat Boy...
This is... This is if Super Meat Boy went Hollywood.
You are the blob.
If Super Meat Boy sold out and went to Hollywood.
And Super Meat Boy but he eats.
Mega Meat Boy.
The Netflix adaptation.
Wait, true.
This is the Netflix adaptation of Super Meat Boy.
Alright, it's a puzzle game?
Why would it be a puzzle?
I just eat.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, it's the Editor's Choice Award.
Nice.
E3.
Rest in peace.
Salute.
Really relaxing game.
Going around eating every human being that you see.
I hate people in this game.
Noodle out of sauce.
Best game I've ever played in my whole life.
God, I love...
I'm fucking... Bro!
Save mine.
Bro, this guy.
New best friend.
The real Super Meat Boy.
I fucking knew it.
I've only played for three hours but it's been mouthful of content.
Wait, what?
Okay, is this... I swear, this is a skill issue.
The novelty of playing as a monster wears off fairly quickly once you realize there really isn't much challenge overall.
And the level design boils down to finding new few switches to open doors.
More interesting mechanics start to get introduced near the end.
However, the game as a whole is very short and they don't do much with...
Is this another skill issue?
Um, actually...
Um, the novelty wears off fairly quickly.
It's not hard enough.
But it gets so boring too.
It's reverse skill issue.
He's actually kinda right?
Nooooo!
It was... This game is too amazing actually.
Just be worse at the game to enjoy them.
Either be worse at the game so we can enjoy games again or be better at games so we can enjoy them.
Alright!
And that was our last recommendation!
Every game recommendation has passed.
Every game you guys suggested other than the ones I vetoed, um, made it through.
We got... Let's see...
I know one of my mods was making a list.
Are you still here?
Can you give me my list?
Uh, we approved...
Amid Evil, Brutal Legend, Halo, EDF...
Oh yeah!
Wait, we have to have a poll.
I almost forgot.
Which version of EDF?
4.1 or 5?
Alright.
We almost forgot the poll.
Okay, so almost...
Uh...
Every game that was suggested by you guys made it to the finals.
And won!
So we got EDF, whichever version that wins.
Gurumon, Prey, Devil May Cry 5, Dragon Ball Z, Sign, A Hat in Time, Space Marine, Project Nexus, Rain World, and Carrion.
And Inscription and Bomb Rush Cyberfunk.
Oh my god, so many games.
Um, at least I saved money on the Steam sale.
Love saving money.
Hahaha!
Haha!
Lads!
Damn!
I can't believe Doki doesn't appreciate the widespread appeal of games without the 1800 Silver...
About the 1800 Silver Age of climbing!
One of these days, I'll find a VTuber who'll play the Scottish Mountain game.
Thank you, Luda Super Chat!
Thank you!
One of these days, somebody will play my favorite game!
The game about Scottish climbing.
That is like a very, very specific, like, niche you have there, sir.
That is extremely specific.
Hahaha!
Someday, you'll find that streamer.
Someday!
I believe in you!
Hahaha!
He's gonna be on a long search.
Alright.
But yeah, that was really fun, though!
I had a really great time, like, looking up Steam games with all of you guys and reading the reviews.
I'm sorry, like, it wasn't...
It was only...
I, like...
I, like, put my cut off at, like, two hours because, like, I wanted to rest a little bit today, so that's why I had to cut the stream to two hours today.
Um, so, like, I didn't do a lot of...
I wanted to do more game suggestions, but I don't want to overdo it, because I don't want to overdo myself with getting burnt out and everything.
So that's why I had a little cut off for myself.
Um, anyway!
I hope you guys had a great time!
I had a great time talking with all of you guys and hanging out and just looking at video games together.
It looks like five is winning!
So I'm gonna do a countdown for everybody for the last final vote, in which I don't think...
I honestly don't think 4.1 is gonna win looking at these numbers, but I will entertain the thought about giving you guys more time to vote.
So, ten, nine, eight, seven, six, seven, eight, nine, ten!
Six, five, four, three, two, one!
And pull!
Yeah!
EDF five!
Win's in the end!
Anyway guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!